E
RIO GRANDE VALLEY SECTOR,
TESTING POSITIVE FOR COVID IN
JUST THE FIRST TWO WEEKS
OF JULY.
THIS MORNING, THERANDE
VALLEY BORDER PATROL CHIEF
REPORTS THAT THERE ARE ACTUALLY
44 AGENTS CURRENTLY HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE.
THERE ARE FIVE OF THEM THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE HOSPITAL,
CONDITIONS UNKNOWN.
FORMER ACTING DIRECTOR OF
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT, RON VITIELLO, JOINS
ME NOW.
THERE ARE SO MANY DISTURBING
FACTS COMING OUT AND DETAILS
BEHIND THIS ON MULTIPLE FRONTS.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS, LET'S
TALK ABOUT THAT.
44 HAVE TESTED POSITIVE, FIBER
IN THE HOSPITAL.
THIS COULD BE PREVENTED.
THAT'S THE MOST FRUSTRATING PART
IN ALL OF THIS.
>> IT'S VERY CONCERNING.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO THE
WORKFORCE, THE CBP, THE OFFICERS
AND AGENTS.
THEY CAN'T SKYPE TO THEIR JOBS,
YOU CAN'T PATROL THE BORDER OVER
YOUR COMPUTER SCREEN.
THEY HAVE TO BE AT THOSE
LOCATIONS, AND THEY ARE EXPOSED
TO PEOPLE COMING FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
ONLY HALF OF THE UNITED STATES
IS VACCINATED, SO THE PEOPLE
COMING FROM THESE THIRD WORLD
COUNTRIES HAVE MUCH LESS
VACCINATION.
IN THAT PIPELINE THEY ARE IN
CROWDED CONDITIONS.
AT THE BORDER THEY ARE IN STASH
HOUSES AND AGENTS HAVE TO
INTERACT WITH THOSE PEOPLE AND
TAKE THEM INTO CUSTODY.
A JOB BY ITSELF IS RISKY, THEN
YOU ADD THE PANDEMIC ON TOP OF
THAT.
THEY HAVE TO INTERACT WITH THESE
FOLKS FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND THEN GOT BACK HOME TO THEIR
OWN FAMILIES.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE STRESS THEY
ARE UNDER IN REGULAR CONDITIONS.
BUT THE PANDEMIC ON TOP OF THAT,
IT'S VERY CONCERNING.
>> Julie: THE NUMBERS ARE JUST
STAGGERING AND THEY HAVEN'T
GOTTEN ANY BETTER SINCE THIS
ADMINISTRATION TOOK CONTROL OF
OUR COUNTRY IN JANUARY.
BUT HERE'S WHAT I WAS ALSO
SURPRISED TO HEAR, WHEN MIGRANTS
ARE TAKEN INTO CUSTODY, BORDER
PATROL DOESN'T ACTUALLY
TYPICALLY TEST THEM FOR COVID
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
THEY COME INTO THIS COUNTRY,
THEY MAY HAVE COVID, THEY MAY
NOT, THEY ARE THEN LUMPED
TOGETHER WITH MANY OTHER
MIGRANTS WHO ARE EVENTUALLY
GOING TO BE TRANSFERRED.
THAT'S WHEN THEY ACTUALLY TEST
THEM.
WHEN THEY TRANSFER THEM EITHER
TO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
OR HHS CUSTODY, OR THEY ARE
ACCOMPANIED -- IF THEY ARE
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN, TO
NONGOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION, OR
IF THEY ARE PART OF A FAMILY
UNIT, THEY ARE TESTED AGAIN.
THERE'S A BIG GAP AND THAT IS
WHY THE SPREAD, COULD THIS BE
PART OF THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM?
>> IT IS PART OF THE PROBLEM,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A CHALLENGE
WITH THE LOGISTICS.
MANY, MANY PEOPLE ARE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER, THE
FACILITIES GET OVERCROWDED,
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH SPACE FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING, AND THE
TESTING OCCURS, LIKE YOU SAID,
ON THE BACK AND NECK OF THE
CUSTODY AS THEY ARE BEING TO
ANOTHER AGENCY AS IT RELATES TO
CHILDREN AND SOME OF THE
FAMILIES.
YEAH, THIS IS CAUSING A PROBLEM
FOR BORDER COMMUNITIES, AS WELL.
THEY ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO HANDLE
ALL THIS EXTRA TRAFFIC AND
TESTING AND ISOLATION AND
HOSPITALIZATION.
SO THE BORDER COMMUNITIES ARE
NOT PREPARED F